the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
view modal analysis I figured most I've
heard lots of students have had
questions and you could use a little
practice on this so that's we're going
to do huh
yeah solvent solving the whole thing so
but let's still start with the usual
concepts I haven't even raced what we
had last time but this is what the
students in the last group said about
key concepts or the week if you want to
add something to it pick up modal
analysis multi degree of freedom
transfer functions and then modal
analysis more specifically response to
initial conditions response to
steady-state harmonic inputs anything
else that was significant conceptually
new in the last week add to that and
then the second thing I had just what
are issues that are muddy for you not
quite clear things you want to learn bit
more about have questions about last
class was more on transfer functions for
multi degree freedom systems and solving
initial condition problems is what one
student was interested in about from
using modal analysis anybody but any of
you have questions about things that you
want practice on yeah so I understand
how to get
mass and spring and whatever matrices
for the cue system so I can set it up as
the M QB q KQ right but from there I
don't know how to go back and solve for
X right so we'll go through that we're
going to run through a complete modal
analysis today all the steps that you
need to do to make it happen so anything
else that you've got a question about
that I might be able to get to okay
let's get rolling this will take a
little while so the problem for the day
is if you recall last time we had this
demo of this double pendulum right now
we're going to take that double pendulum
and make the masses unequal so will the
masses are equal here but they could be
unequal M 1 M 2 there each half a
kilogram but we're changing the links a
little bit 1.14 l1 and 1.0 meters for l2
so there's slightly different lengths
and that'll make this system not
symmetric so it won't have 1 1 and 1
minus 1 mode shapes a little weak spring
in the middle possibility of having some
dashpot here connected to a a non moving
wall another dashpot here and the
possibility of having harmonic
excitations f1 on this one f2 on that
one
the whole system's been linearized the
equations of motion look something like
this mass damping matrix stiffness
matrix of course it has gravity terms in
it as well as spring terms and it's been
linearized and the whole thing what kind
of motion is it force is it a force
equation or a moment equation are they
force or a moment or both you know we
can have mixed ones like the cart
problem with the pendulum as one force
equation and one equation with units of
torque this one has units of what yeah
these are both this is moments about
point a and moments about
might be give you the two equation so
this is a torque equation so if you need
to look and see if things inside here
make sense
so the MGL the nonlinear equation the
restoring torque is MGL sine theta
linearize is just data so mg L 1 theta
is a torque on the first mass em 2 gee L
2 theta is a torque on the second mass
and so forth and K 1 L 1 squared Y the L
1 squared this term here gets multiplied
by a theta 1 so what is that what's K 1
L 1 squared theta 1 what kind of a
torque it what is that is it to make
sense or its units correct so first of
all it's K 1 L 1 times theta yes of
course what's L 1 times theta physically
that is what that's the distance that
that thing moves right and end of
displacement times a spring constant
gives you a force and then that force
times a moment arm gives you a tour so
makes sense K L 1 squared theta 1 is a
torque about point a caused by a
displacement theta 1 assuming this one
is 0 when you do it that's the response
that's the torque caused by a
displacement of theta 1 only ok all
right so that's our equations of motion
linearize this is the mass matrix this
is the stiffness matrix that you would
get if you go into there and substitute
in these values yeah
this one here this is 2x2 matrix and it
has to be it's a two degree freedom
system this is this is K 1 1 K 1 1 term
this is the k12 term the cake - one term
and the k2 - term yeah I got a little
squeezed here this space there's a m2 g
l2 that shouldn't be squared plus K l2
squared alright you're sure that's what
it ought to read like mg L 2 KL 2
squared and then each of these are minus
K l1 l2 minus K l1 l2 all of this this
will be this is all in a handout which
will be put up on the stellar website
and just so in terms of you know
reviewing for final and things to go
look at for almost every recitation
we've done this term professor Gossard
the other recitation instructor has
written up the complete problem that was
discussed with its solution and put it
on the website you don't even have to
copy this stuff down that's all posted
and those are really you know each
recitation we essentially done a problem
that is the sort of the objective lesson
for the week so they're a good place to
go review so this whole problem is uh it
will be up on there and we found a
mistake actually on this and I think
well it'll get fixed before it gets put
up but I think this had a zero in here
and that's actually wrong or something
got transposed in writing that's the
correct mass okay so you got you have
these numbers we're not want you to work
this stuff out because I want to focus
on the modal analysis so let's see here
I'm going to ask you a question first so
we're going to begin this yeah
oh I wish somebody asked a question in
the last class and I wrote drew that up
there but if you put a torsional damper
up there some CT value what how would it
appear in the equation of motion would
it have l1 l2 Squared's in it no if we
just simply just appear as a plus CT
beta 1 or theta 2 wherever it's applied
directly they 2 1 dot okay first
question write down on your piece of
paper so I'm not going to make you go to
the board today but your argon and I
want you to take a minute and write
things down and then we'll check it and
see if everybody agrees the the way the
reason we can do modal analysis is
because of thing something we call the
modal expansion theorem it's basically
the fundamental statement that says we
can do this so what is the modal
expansion theorem you can write it down
and mathematically if you want just as a
little mate little linear algebra
expression or you can write it out in
words so take 30 seconds and write down
what makes modal analysis work what
basic proposition
all right somebody help me out what's
the what is the modal expansion theorem
what does it say
the system can be described as a
weighted sum of weighted sum of the
motions of the each of the natural modes
okay so that's statement the most
succinct way to say it is in the
original generalized coordinates you can
express them as u Q all right
U is the matrix of what
no made this mode shapes and the queues
are the individual modal coordinates
right so this expanded says that this
two degree freedom system has two
generalized coordinates theta1 and
theta2 and the response of either of the
actual motion of the system expressed in
the generalized coordinates can be made
up as the sum of each of the modal
coordinates the Q's of eyes scaled to
the shape of the mode shape for that
mode so this multiplies the mode shape
and that so everything contributed by
mode one will move in the shape of mode
one and that will be reflected in the
motion of the system 'its and you this
case it's a two by two to two degree
freedom system here's the mode shape of
mode one times Q one which we're going
to solve for plus the mode shape of mode
two times its modal motion okay that's
the modal expansion theorem all right
this allows you to in order to do this
you have to solve for these Q eyes so
what is the equation motion that governs
the behavior of each of the modal
coordinates write it down what's the
whole reason we do this is one
particular equation of motion that every
one of them satisfies
so equation of motion not asking for
solution I just want the equation of
motion that governs the governs these
modal motions
I think I'm getting a minute to think
about it
okay somebody help me out what's the
equation of motion that I can write that
will describe the motion of any one of
these modal coordinates Q I Christina
pardon
well yeah but it's basically a very
simple equation of motion which you
should be familiar with by now what's it
look like for any one of these modal
coordinates what is the equation of
motion that governs it why do we go to
all this trouble there's a reason for
doing this big is because ah the single
degree of freedom oscillator equation
right this is the reason we do this
single degree of freedom systems are
mathematically simple and you've been
you've seen them since high school
you've seen them in 1803 it's the second
order linear differential equation that
looks like this and you know ever you
already know everything there is to be
known about that equation and that's why
one of the reasons why we do this you
don't have to solve a complex set of
simultaneous differential equations you
just have to know one and so the ice one
you need to know the ice modal mass the
IKE modal damping the I model stiffness
and the modal force and we've in this
course we've taught you how to solve two
kinds of two kinds of single degree of
freedom system problems one is
responsible initial conditions when
they're forces on the right hand side is
0 and the other is this steady-state
response to a harmonic input some cosine
Omega T kind of input so you that's what
we focused on in this course because
it's vibration we're interested in so we
solved this equation for two kinds of
problems now to do modal analysis you
need to be able to find these quantities
these we call the modal masses the modal
damping coefficients the modal
stiffnesses how do you get those how for
example write down in your favor what
equation what linear algebra thing do
you have to work out to get the modal
masses for the system let's say all of
them I want it's a two degree freedom
system what's the state what's the mass
the linear algebra you have to work out
to get the mo
all masses
how many help me what is it yeah Oh
matrix lasted half
all right
all right
the mole forces are you transpose F the
modal masses and I've drawn these little
diagonal marks in here to remind you
these matrices become all diagonal when
you do the modal analysis coordinate
transformation I'll call it
so the modal masses are u transpose mu
and this M is a matrix and it's the
original mass matrix of the system modal
stiffness matrix u transpose K u and the
modal damping matrix u transpose Cu but
this one can be problematic you have to
have to force this one to behave
these are guaranteed to behave alright
so for this problem and I know some of
you are a little rusty calculating these
things so there's the modal mass matrix
and here is the modal the matrix of
eigenvectors or mode shapes of the
system u is made up of columns and each
column is one of the mode shapes and the
convention is to order them by the from
the first mode to the anthem ode where
the order is established by the natural
frequencies the lowest natural frequency
is 1st 2nd 2nd up to the highest natural
frequency anyway here's mode 1 here's
mode 2 for this system you have to once
you have to choose a way in which to
normalize the mode shapes I choose to
normalize them use usually I say I'm
going to make the top element of them 1
and I do that whatever if you run that
if you do MATLAB like you do there's a
function called AG which means eigen
value do I give a it'll give you the
eigen values of matrix a and it'll give
them back to you unnormalized and
unordered and so you can write a little
program to put it all in Nice order but
if if MATLAB gave you back
a the mode shapes for this for a system
and it said well the mode shapes of the
system are it's a 2 by 2 system 2 and
point 4 and point 6 and point five you
know that the vectors are the mode
shapes the columns
how would you normalize those how would
you make the top element one in this
first one divided what by two entire
column by two just factor 2 out so this
would become 2 over 2 and 0.4 over 2 and
you know that's 1 and point 2 so you've
just normalized that vector so the top
element is 1 so you pick what do you
have to normalize it could you use them
this way sure but once chosen once the
normalization is chosen the key to doing
modal analysis is you have to stick with
it you can't move you can't mess with
that half way through or you totally
screw up the solution so you pick your
normalization when you calculate the
natural frequencies and mode shapes you
pick a normalization and you must ride
with that all the way through including
putting it back together in at the end
this summation ok so let's do I want you
to do this computation calculate the
modal masses for this problem that means
you have to remember what a transpose is
there's the modal that's the modal
matrix and the modal mass matrix is
right there so I actually just do the
arithmetic take a few minutes yeah
all going to be very closer then again
on the exam on the exam we'd either make
it so simple that you can in fact do it
in your head or on paper or we want to
ask the question that you have to do it
that way or we'll accept an answer where
you put it down but don't have to
multiply it out so just do this one just
to see if you have the remember the
mechanics of doing the linear algebra to
get that okay somebody having an answer
for me here for the modal mass matrix
what's the first element somebody help
me
give me a number and then everybody else
can check you
say again point two five four zero point
two five four okay
what about the second I'll put this
element over here big up yeah better be
zero
what about this one down here all right
how about this one
okay come on
so did you give me the first did you
give me the first one so you're
authorized to change this no wait
okay you got point to what eight five
nine eight and this zero zero how about
this second one down here now
3.48 anybody else get anything different
so let's we have 6:05 0 0 and 0.5 and
we're multiplying that
so if you're looking for just one of
them by the way or my eraser go all you
need is the one of the modal masses the
only ones that give you nonzero results
is when you compute u transpose for mode
R mu4 mode R so if you're only looking
for the second one you only have to do
the calculation for that mode so this
send becomes a set of matrix matrix
matrix you only have to do a couple of
vectors so this looks like for mode two
- what Oh two is one and minus one point
six nine four nine times point six zero
five zero zero and point five times one
and minus one point six nine four nine
so to get just one modal mass this is m2
to get just one modal mass now you only
have to do that calc you can only have
to do the computation using one of the
mode shapes so it's this times that and
this times that gives you some numbers
back 0.6 oh five and half of this about
point eight and then you take that and
multiply it again anybody can give me
somebody to give you this second number
have a 3.48 anybody get any different
pardon okay there are about 18 of you
nobody can do this calculation
say again alright I have a two point one
three a two point oh okay there you are
okay so if you were having trouble
sorting that out probably good thing to
go back and review a little bit a little
bit of your linear algebra okay if you
do you transpose K you you get this yeah
okay I'm going to guess where I'm going
next so you tried to get the stiffness
matrix u transpose K u
you get this you Trent we're going to
leave the damping matrix for a minute we
need that we need the modal excitations
so I'm just going to do a particular
problem I'm going to say let's let F to
be zero we'll only have one force and
the first force will be f1 cosine Omega
T and so now I need to do u transpose F
so here's u transpose
here's the F's and I guess I ought to
keep my cosine Omega T here so you
multiply that out what do you get yeah
well because f1 is just the applied
force but the equation of motion that
we're working with if you go back and
look at it
what is the forces on the right-hand
side the forces are have to be moments
right we're putting a force down there
it's a moment equation we need the
moments about the pivot so it's the
force times l1 or a force times l2 you
have to you will a [ __ ] you know these
kind of problems are easiest to do once
you reduce them to numbers
I'm leaving the force in it as a
variable at the moment just so you can
see how it carries through the problem
but I'm just saying in the real problem
there let's say there is no f2 there is
an f1 and the f1 of T looks like a
magnitude f1 times cosine Omega T that's
the only force I have in the system but
we're working with equations of motion
in the equation of motion is the
right-hand side f1 l1 and f2 l - you
have to retain the l1 and l2 is in order
to have the correct equation of motion
so when we say this is this is kind of
just a generic form this is the modal
force vector is the mode shape matrix
times the modal excitations in the
original coordinate so I just wrote F
here but what this really means is this
is f1 l1 + f2 l2 these are the real
generalized forces in the system ok
they're the real generalized forces now
I've let F to be 0 so the real general
only generalized force is f1 l1 cosine
Omega T I multiply that by u transpose
to get and what do I get this pretty
simple calculation
this becomes f1 l1 coast and f1 l1 coast
so the two modal forces are identical
yeah well the fee doesn't come out until
the answer if the what is the fee mean
what's that phase angle mean if when if
you remember we're doing steady state
problems in which f1 l1 for example if
it's cosign is we're just assuming it
looks like that right and we're looking
for a solution theta1 and actually can't
we can't quite go there yet we're doing
single degree freedom problems right
we're we are looking for a solution for
q1 we turn this into a modal force q but
it happens to be the capital q1 the
modal force is f1 l1 right cosine Omega
T so we that's the input the output is Q
little Q of T the modal coordinate and
what is it looked like we we're only
doing steady state no transients it
looks like a response that looks like
this but it's shifted but this I'll draw
this so its peak is right here and
cosine is its Matt it's shifted in time
by this amount between this peak is here
versus the peak being there and that we
can represent as a phase angle remember
one period from here to here is two pi
radians so some portion of that period
is an angle interpreters an angle or you
can interpret it as a time delay and
this then has the form of some q1 magnet
dude cosine Omega t minus that faceshift
so it's only that's only the thing the
phase shift means is cosine in doesn't
mean exactly the response out is going
to be exactly in the same perfectly in
time with it it could be shifted now you
know that it for a single degree freedom
system at resonance what's the phase
angle you remember that it's always one
number it's PI over two a shift of PI
over two if you remember your
trigonometry takes you from cosine to
sine or sine to cosine it's trying to
tell you that the response is shifted by
exactly a quarter of a cycle PI over two
and the reason for that is that at
resonance all of the excitation is going
into overpowering the damper and the
dampers motion is proportional to
velocity and if velocity if displacement
looks like cosine velocity looks like
one derivative of it which is sine so
that PI over two says it's that the
response velocity is in phase with the
force and that makes sense something I
hadn't said in lecture but it really
meant to is think I want to think about
something here single degree freedom
system
well we even write the one we're working
with M 1 Q 1 double dot plus C 1 Q 1 dot
plus K 1 Q equals some F 1 L 1 cosine
Omega T and I can let Omega M be atom
make it 1 but this is the equation of
motion right let's plug in we're saying
we're going to do this right at the and
we know the response of this is Q 1 is
some magnitude cosine Omega t minus
aphasic
we know we can plug that in we get minus
m1 Omega squared Q 1 plus K 1 Q 1 plus
minus C 1 Omega Q 1 and this one goes
like sine Omega t minus V this one here
needs to get multiplied this term gets
multiplied by cosine Omega t minus V
alright you plug that into this this
term in this term but both behave like
cosine this term one derivative being
it's like minus sine one derivative of
cosine gives you minus sine right
and when Omega equals Omega one so when
you're right at resonance here what
happens this is a squared and I put I
squared down here there we go so this
Omega but now I'm going to let it be
right at Omega one what is it mega one
in terms of case and hips
a 1 over m1 otherwise one of the checks
you can make when you finish doing your
modal met if you take that modal mass
and the modal stiffness and you divide
seven point nine six by point eight five
nine eight that had better be Omega one
squared it's a good way to check that
you've done all your arithmetic right
alright I'm going to plug in Omega one
squared here equals k1 over m1 so I put
in this becomes minus m1 K 1 over m 1
which is minus k1 right hmm plus k1 at
resonance this term accounts for the
inertial force in the system the force
required to accelerate the mass whether
this is a force equation this account's
or the force required to push the spring
amazing thing the thing happens is at
resonance the inertial forces exactly
cancel the day of the spring forces and
the equation of motion reduces to minus
C 1 Omega 1 Q 1 sine Omega 1 t minus a
phase angle equals this case f1 l1
cosine Omega 1t so how to satisfy that
equation what phase angle will satisfy
that equation has to be PI over 2 if you
put PI over 2 in here this minus sign
turns into plus cosine and on you're
left with C 1 Omega 1 q1 equals f1 l1 so
all of the exciting force goes into
pushing the dashpot so that's what
rot-weiss why you get the big peak in
the transfer function it takes no force
to move the spring it takes no force to
accelerate the mass they exactly cancel
and all the forces available to derive
just the dashpot all right
so let's move on how do we need to get
to our answer here so the last piece of
this is we've now know the modal forces
and your assignment is to let's let
Omega see there's my I do this somewhere
I guess not
yes I erased it so we can pick anything
we want let's let Omega equal Omega 2
we're going to drive this thing at the
natural frequency of the second mode
that's the excitation what do you expect
which mode do you expect to dominate the
response second mode why because you're
you are driving it you know it's got a
transfer function that looks like this
and you're driving it right here and
where are you driving that if you're
doing that where where are you on the
transfer function for the first mode
mega - it's a little higher than Omega 1
but not a lot so if this were the first
modes transfer function where would you
be driving it on this transfer function
this is Omega over Omega - yeah you're
over here a little bit you're driving it
a little bit higher than the natural
frequency of mode 1 this would be Omega
2 over Omega 1 on that track so once
sitting here one sitting there which
one's going to be dominate the big one
okay because they have equal modal
forces you'll both happen to be f1 l1 ok
so how do you do that so your lap the
last step in this thing is I want you to
for this for this case find the first
I'll so let's find the second mode
contribution to the response in the
original generalized coordinates it'll
often a quiz would off be written this
way it's trying to make it easier for
you I'm asking for only one modes
contribution what does that actually
mean in the original statement of modal
the modal expansion theorem we know the
total response looks like this right I'm
asking you to give me only the second
modes contribution what am I asking for
just this term so I'm telling you know
if the father was the editor the satisfy
me just tell me what this one is because
I know this is one's going to be the
dominant one okay so how do I do that so
for this problem what is the steady
state response of this do two mode two
only so mathematic you know just in
what's that look like over here
just that second term right it's the
modal mode shape vector for mode two
times q2 of T so you need to tell me how
to find q2 of T - single degree freedom
problem excited by steady-state
excitation
ah magic word transfer function so we
need the magnitude of the this is a
linear problem so the response is
linearly proportional to the force so
magnitude of q1 times a transfer
function looks like the H x over F
transfer function in this case we'd call
it the magnitude of H q2 per unit q2 and
that and that will that multiplied by it
looks like cosine in this case Omega 2 t
minus some v2 that's what we're looking
for
what's this tell me what that looks like
yeah thank you
so in effect what's the transfer
function I want it I want it in all its
detail now that's the magnitude of the
force what's in the numerator of this
numerator
yeah it's in the denominator that I want
just the numerator part which ended this
transfer function expression for a
single degree freedom system what's in
the numerator one over which kk2
modal k2 we're now in modal in the modal
system and in the denominator that
transfer function what's it look like 1
minus Omega squared over in this case
Omega 2 squared squared plus Zeta 2
there we go now in this problem what is
a mega so that'd be what makes this a 2
makes this a 2 this term what happens to
it 1 minus 1 this term this goes to 1
this is 2 Zeta quantity squared square
root just 2 Zeta so this hole at
resonance any one of these single degree
freedom systems that were at resonance
the response is the magnitude of the
force in this case that's positive f1 l1
over k2 times 1 over 2 Zeta 2 so f1 l1
is the modal magnitude of the modal
force divided by K 2 gives you the what
we call the static displacement of the
system and this is a dynamic
amplification so we oftentimes like
quizzes you're asked to do the response
at resonance because it makes all this
algebra so simple and it boils down to
you know 1 over 2 Zeta it's the only
thing left to do is you need a damp we
need the damping ratio for the system so
rather than do that to so now that we're
missing something yet we're missing that
whole thing gets multiplied by cosine
Omega 2t minus a phase angle
what's the phase angle PI over 2 so Q 2
of T is f1 l1 over k1 1 over 2 whoops f1
l1 over k2 1 over 2 Zeta 2 cosine Omega
2 t minus and at the very how do we get
back to generalized coordinates theta 1
and theta 2
right here and we've computed that this
part you multiply it by the mode shape
the mode shape partitions out the
response in the right amount to
coordinate one and the correct amount to
coordinate to INRI in reality what you
do with with damping ratios is you know
we're you're working with real things
out there in the world world if you can
you go up and get the thing a kick and
get your stopwatch out and say how many
cycles does it take the decay and is it
light damping or not if it vibrates a
lot it's usually light damping and if
it's light damping you can force this
damping matrix you can just make forces
to behave even if it isn't perfect and
it is that perfectly adequate useful
answer even if it isn't perfectly
diagonal it just doesn't matter when
it's light damping and so in this
problem what you do is you go estimate
the damping for the system is it huh
looks to me to be about two percent for
mode one and one and a half percent for
mode two and you just say how can I fit
the how can I represent the damping in
the system and the one of the easiest
ones is to say that the original damping
matrix is some alpha times the mass
matrix plus many times the stiffness
matrix that in this problem this problem
and the or you can use any part of that
and if you're only trying to if you're
only trying to match one mode see this
problem it's this system is being driven
at the natural frequency of one mode
that mode is dominating the response
right so we really actually only need a
good model of the damping for that mode
even if you have the completely wrong
damping for the other mode it will have
little effect on its answer because you
not at resonance when in the transfer
functions which look like this at
resonance this happens and you find out
that the only force resisting the input
is the dashpot at low frequencies you
find out that over here the dominant
force is what it takes to move the
spring and the damping isn't very
important and so even if you're wrong by
50% it just doesn't fifty percent of a
little bit compared to the what it takes
to move the spring is not a big deal and
over here it behaves like the mass out
here is called the mass controlled
region over here is a stiffness
controlled region and in the vicinity of
the peak is the damping controlled
region so at low frequency this term
dominates at high frequency that term
dominates and at resonance this is the
dominant term so this case let's let the
damping be some alpha times the mass
matrix then when you do you tcu you get
alpha times the modal mass matrix and
therefore c2 which is the one we care
about is equal to alpha times m2 and we
have m2 our modal mass
point 204 right so that says this is
equal C 2 is equal to alpha time 2.04
and if I want out that's C 2 and how do
I get Zeta 2 Zeta 2 is C 2 over 2 Omega
2 m2 that's just the definition of
damping ratio I know this I know this so
this is going to be alpha times 2.0 4
over 2 Omega 2 m2 and I've measured it
you know I've taken and I'd say I know
this is 0.02 about 2% damping solve for
alpha and you now have the whole thing
that you need you can now find you
that's all that's all you need yeah
this is a simply this is called Rayleigh
damping Lord Rayleigh a hundred and
fifty years ago came out for this and he
just said hey by the way if you model
damping this way you can automatically
make the equations of motion you
transpose C you go diagonal and you have
a two parameter model with which you can
juggle them to make any two damping
ratios of the system be exactly what you
want them to be so it's just you if you
if I left this is alpha and beta then I
would have worked this problem as this
would have been an alpha M plus a beta
kc2 would have been an alpha M - but now
would be equal to alpha M 2 plus beta K
2 and then this still applies except it
have this alpha and a beta and you could
do it for the other equation you can do
it for Zeta 1 you'd have two equations
in two unknowns you satisfy solve for
alpha and beta but think about what I
just did here if I make made a
measurement of the system I said the
damping for mode 2 is 2% do I have to go
through all this junk no because I know
the answer looks like that all I have to
know is what the damping is that's my
approximate solution for the problem
this is just how to satisfy all the
mathematics if you want that perfect
mathematical model for which you can
write out u transpose Cu and get them
well this is one way that you can force
the damper matrix to have the properties
that you want it to but in reality you
just measure the damping and put in the
answer very good this is our last
go-around at recitations see you in
class on Tuesday we'll do something fun
that's not covered on the final exam
I'll give a little review of what's
going to be on the final a list of
what's on it and we'll talk about
strings and beams and things that apply
to pianos and
Islands and so forth